this relationship with information that
you're describing where you present to
evangelicals hey here's some evidence on
let's say covet or or whatnot I think
one of the most powerful forces that
Trump has tapped into is this
anti-institutional sentiment yeah 100
um I use the analogy that for a long
time the relationship between people in
the world I grew up in
evangelicals
their relationship with
you know the news media in general and
and institutions
uh
non-religious institutions mostly
their relationship to that world was uh
was very strained
um if I think I used the metaphor of a
tree where the the branch or the
connective tissue between evangelicals
and and secular Media or secular
institutions was hanging by a thread
and Trump came along and really snapped
it in half and then kind of brought a
lot of people with them into an
alternative epistemic universe and I I
think that issue of epistemology how do
we know what we know
is at the root of so many of the issues
driving our cultural political
dysfunction today yeah especially now
yeah it's why I think Jonathan roush's
book
um the constitution of knowledge
um is so important and it's a start
Jonathan's book is a starting point
because it's it's dense it's uh it needs
a lot more like bringing out of the
lessons he talks about
um into real world applications
but if we can't kind of establish a
baseline of how we produce knowledge
that everyone can kind of share as a
starting point for disagreement and
debate
and also a system for resolving those
disagreements without violence then
um we're going to continue to see I
think a lot of the dysfunction that
we're talking about or that we're seeing
and I think you know you pointed to it
there is this parallel universe that I
grew up in which in some ways was
motivated by a sense that we know better
than people who are not like us who
don't don't believe like like us but it
also creates
um that sense of opposition that sense
of we're going to be persecuted
um they're out to get us uh and and so
all of that is what was going on for a
very long time before Trump ever came
along which was a big part of the mix
and I'm really glad that you are
um are perceiving the ways I think that
I the book lays out how the ground was
seated for a long time
you're enjoying the podcast if you
really like it hit subscribe and then
YouTube will notify you every time we
have a bang up new guest thank you